Truyền đội số quốc gia đang được bệ mấy mục tiêu lễ người dân làm chúng tâm trong đó số hóa sĩ vụ công là một trong những vụ trong tâm giảm nước ca chất lượng phục vụ và giảm chí vý sát hội.
Trong quá trình này, nhiều điều phương đã trình hai các trạm dị vụ công số với sự tham gia đông hành tay trợ của ngân hàng át gree bang.
Hệ thống vào hùng kiế ốc thông mình cũng có trất giải pháp phổ trợ sách thử cấp bản sống số tại được địa từ.
Đến này các trạm dị vụ công số số à truy bánh tay trợ đã được trình hai tại Hanoi, thành khóa khoảng ninh, ninh, mình và đảnh.
Hỗ trợ người dân thực hiện tụ thủ thành chính nhanh chống, thật hiện trên thu chứng số.
Mới đây đã nắng đưa vào bản hàng thêm người một trạm dị vụ công số, có phần mở giọc hạt tân phục vụ quá trình xây dẫn chỉ quyền số và đối thị thông mình.
Thông qua kỳ ốc thông mình người dân có thể chủ đậu định dành số hóa dễ tờ, lo khô sơ và nhận tiếp khỏa hoàn toàn trên thu chứng số.
Hệ thông ứng dụng chỉ truyền nhân tạo AI, con người nhận giản kỳ từ quan học OCR và nên tạm dữ liệu số nằm kìm xa,
chuyển quá, liệu chợ và tải sự dụng tại nhiều.
Mô hình có phần giản hủ sơ dễ, giúp nắng thời gian giải bếc thử tụ thành chính, trong thời gian nân cao tính miệng và hiệu khoảng vụ.
Theo angry bán trong thời gian tởi, đơn vị sẽ tiếp tục chuyển quá và kết lối hệ thông, để tích hợp các sĩ của nân thàn trên Dior Stonging,
giúp người dân thực hiện cả dị cụ công và giang dịch gái chính tại cuộc một nghiệm vụ vụ.